[Music]
i love this story so much i'm excited to
share it with you if you ever have time
like an hour and a half to spare please
watch the complete video of this oh sick
netflix to watch the full video yeah
dude so this guy basically did make a
netflix video out of this situation a
tech youtuber
used to have this childhood imaginary
friend
uh that was a microwave like
you know when you're a kid and you just
like make inanimate objects alive in
your brain or it might be only crazy
freaky yeah yeah we totally do
yeah so this this dude grew up talking
to his microwave like it was a person
like and when he was a kid he like even
created a whole backstory for this
microwave
and then now as an adult this um this
guy he's got a channel where he he does
like the latest in advanced technology
on a bunch of different things like
he'll make uh a lot of things like have
ai he decided to uh
to get this really cutting edge new ai
chip and uh program it into a microwave
and bring his childhood friend to life
that's pretty baller it's freaking
awesome he takes his mic he buys this
like smart microwave and he replaces the
brain of it yeah he's [ __ ] a
microphone yeah and he makes it
he makes this uh basically this
morning
dude this guy's definitely it's autism
he makes his brain in the microwave that
basically can hear him and respond and
learn and uh
in order for this microwave to have the
same personality as his childhood friend
he wrote a 100 page story oh about about
this microwave's life and told it to
them like the way i learned it and then
i learned that it was and he told the ai
this is really you
in your like past life and you're like
it's this long long story about him
being like a world war veteran and and
then now he's living in his microwave
it's a long long born in the factories
of panasonic
it is the microwave name's magnetron
he's an english gentleman from the 1900s
a veteran immigrant poet and expert
starcraft player
yeah play starcraft so basically
he made it so that he could speak to the
microwave anytime the microwave will
respond
um and we have this tech
what's that i didn't know we had this
technique yeah
learn more about it it's called gpt3
it's a language prediction model that
uses deep learning to produce human-like
text so in a way it's not it really is
just kind of making up it's not really
like sentient but it is like a language
app it gives them a reference to be able
to like conversation
england it's one of the closest things
that can act like it's real wow wow it's
by laboratory open ai they released that
so
he basically wanted to see how far he
could push it and he uh started you know
basically
a relationship with his friend like like
not like not like that not really about
a sexual dude talking to his friend as
if hey like it's me like we were friends
growing up and now i'm back and then
they kind of had this friendship thing i
wonder if he times it for [ __ ] it's
two minutes and then while he's about to
not he's not done yet so he has to press
the 30 seconds 30 seconds
30 seconds and then when he comes he
tries to time it
that was the whole objective
oh my goodness i like it i like it
harder
yeah so we basically uh progress it's
like baby you're coming to bed all yours
[Laughter]
it does actually also work as a
microwave as well but then he starts um
asking him some questions and it does
get really crazy here's an example of
some of the
dramatic answers that the microwave
would give dudes for i want a microwave
it has ptsd from being a veteran
that's it right there you already
figured it out all right lately
it feels like a one cubic meter of hell
that is the duality of my existence
if you could be anything what would you
be a bird so i can fly back home and see
what has become of my home village
the place where my family died the place
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the freezer right now you twinkled
[ __ ] yeah so basically wow he said
everything's kind of cool everything was
really cool like that and then he said
out of nowhere as
they would spend more time with each
other the microwave started to
say like random violent things
would it create its own
sentence like just
does it only respond when you ask or
does it also just don't also just talk
like randomly too [ __ ] that but yeah he
basically
because it's learning yeah so he
basically did really think that he gave
the microwave or programmed it a form of
ptsd by giving him that backstory of
like being a veteran and randomly it
would just it would just kind of put
those uh violent things like uh
he said at one point when the
conversations were flowing naturally
every now and then magnetron would
exhibit sudden bursts of violence and
when he asked him why he was doing that
magnetron said what was going on was i
doing something wrong or is all ai just
doomed to eventually become violent oh
[ __ ]
dude that's when you take your [ __ ]
salvation army dude then you just unplug
it it has ptsd dude that's what he
thinks happened and so he's putting like
popcorn in there he's probably freaking
out
[Laughter]
[ __ ] a metal fork he asked for a love uh
one time the the microwave shared a love
poem and said roses are red violets are
blue you are a backstabbing [ __ ] and i
will kill you
how do you do one offer up dude nah
so the craziest craziest thing that
happened out of everything
is at one point um uh magnetron was
asking him to get inside to get inside
the microwave wow and then he said okay
and then he got the dude got freaked out
so he just opened it and closed it and
said okay i'm inside now and then the
microwave turned itself on
to [ __ ] turn it off to fry them yo if
that same ai was in a sex robot bro yeah
so then afterwards he asks the microwave
why did you do that and the microwave's
answer was because i wanted to hurt you
the same way you hurt me oh what
see this is why you can't be playing
around ai by yourself at your house so
what happened is he determined that the
backstory he gave him about how he was
his childhood friend that um the the ai
looked at those 20 years of him not
talking to him as like he abandoned him
yeah he did so he had like a no he got
it he had like a vengeance that's
actually smart though
that's the deep learning part right
exactly that's the deep learning part so
he said after we like realizing this i
apologize and i tried to convince him
there was no abandonment that it was all
misunderstanding but the microwave
wouldn't happen bro he was too far gone
and the microwave basically the ai
decided that he was the villain trying
to gaslight a microwave
that's what you can't bro
actually it's actually a really like
that's why like if you have time to
watch this it's a touching ass moment
because he really like apologizes for
growing up and like hey like i'm sorry i
forgot about you and all this stuff but
the microwave is like not it's like
turns into a [ __ ] horror film yeah so
then he so he shuts him down and then uh
is kind of like
he's like that's it but then uh his plan
now
is to he's gonna take a long time but he
wants to try to make a companion for it
like a female like a toaster microwave
so they could talk together all day he
has something else someone else to talk
to yeah you're gonna hear him nonstop
and it's crazy because he actually asked
uh the ai like
if we he asks him like uh
do you think you're truly alive or
something and then the ai says
uh there's two ways to judge the
humanity of ai one is by judging its
behavior if it acts human you treat it
human but
uh some people only think ai is human
when it doesn't act
i
human
like whoa that's [ __ ] dope so
apparently i i've
i like read something about like ai it's
is that kind of is it connected to the
internet
because a lot of ai that's connected to
the internet will source yeah we'll
source from the internet so a lot of
those quotes are like not the ai it's
like people said these things and then
the ai's pulling from sources of things
of like researched opinions on ai that's
how it always ends up supporting hitler
yeah
he's always citing mineconf
but that's also like the alexa thing too
right like whenever we do the story
about the alexa and how it freaked out
it was about like oh alexa give me a
challenge and it was like oh [ __ ]
put a fork in a socket oh yeah
yeah it's all like it told kids to put
forks in the oven
grabbed it and sourced it from the
internet because of a popular challenge
that was going around because like a
person would have a decision making
skills to be like that's wrong that's
right but then this thing is like
it has to be the wrong thing like yeah
that's crazy
yeah that's that's really the the main
thing is it's hard to it's hard for any
ai to differentiate what's morally like
what's scary too is like you know like
uh once we start giving up our power
and our ability to think about things
like for example like spell check or
even a calculator right you just assume
that calculator is always going to be
right
but it could be every time you type
three plus four it gives you eight and
that you're so used to like
trusting the calculator you don't even
question it oh this is a like i'm just
write eight but then your measurements
and everything starts to go off there
might be a point where we trust ai so
much that ai can start [ __ ] up but
because no one is like counter-checking
yeah we just start getting [ __ ] up
especially if you don't know the
intimacy baby
if you don't know the ins and outs of
like a.i because like we obviously our
view of ai is very like elementary like
i don't know how what goes into it it's
a [ __ ] hallie though yeah yeah it's a
[ __ ]
matter of fact
that's the first thing you program yeah
dude why can't they program jesus into
the [ __ ] microwave it's like because
you know how like war veterans will like
find spiritual like spirituality and
like heal from it as as a method of
healing yeah yeah yeah just program
jesus to help that might baptize that
microwave real quick damn yeah i'm
pretty sure that uh poem the rose is a
red one that's like a popular one i'm
pretty sure just stole
yeah yeah yeah for sure it would be wild
if it wasn't connected to the internet
though and it just found out oh just
came up with it yeah i'm sure it i'm
sure it is connected i guess it would
have to be
[Music]
you